good afternoon I'm Caitlyn youngquist
with the University of Wyoming extension
and I'm going to talk to you a little
bit today about soil testing for Gardens
soil testing can be a very useful tool
uh for gardeners and hopefully I'll be
able to share with you some information
today that will make it easier and um
more useful for
you one thing to keep in mind when we're
talking about soil there are a lot of
different
factors chemistry is an important part
of managing soil biology and physics and
when it comes to soil testing what we're
specifically talking about is the
chemistry of the soil so we're looking
at the pH or the acidity the salt
content your macronutrients nitrogen
phosphorus and potassium and the
micronutrients when it comes to biology
what we're looking at is the nutrient
availability for the plants uh crop
condition the the microorganisms living
in the soil we're looking at bacteria
and fungi earthworms the organic carbon
content of the soil which is what feeds
the soil biology disease pressure there
are a lot of different factors we look
at with soil biology I'm not going to
talk about that much today but there is
a different set of tests that can be
done to look specifically at the
biological condition of your soil but
the best thing to do really there is to
look at crop condition are the plants
healthy and are there earthworms in your
garden those are the two most important
things really as gardeners that you can
look at and when it comes to physics we
look at things like erosion and
compaction um how and water infiltration
how does the water move through the soil
does it P puddle on top of the soil does
the soil dry out very quickly and then
tilt the workability of the soil um does
it just look and feel like really
healthy soil so these are all different
factors we look at when managing soil
there's different ways and different
tools and methodologies to test for a
lot of these different factors but today
we're going to talk about specifically
the chemistry of the soil and that's
what a soil um nutrient test will show
you it's greatly impacted by fertilizer
and water
and the way we have an impact on soil
physics or the physical condition of the
soil is through disturbance and bare
soil primarily so tillage and leaving
our soil bare and then the way we
improve or impact the biology of the
soil is through plant roots keeping
living plant roots in the soil as long
as possible and adding amendments like
manure and compost organic materials to
the soil and when we have all three of
these things Balan the biology chemistry
and physics of the soil we have a really
healthy functioning high functioning
system so keep in mind when you're
managing a soil to keep all of these
factors in mind today we're just going
to talk about
chemistry so why might you soil test as
a gardener there are a few different
reasons the primarily would be to
identify problems so something in your
garden is struggling there are certain
crops you can't grow well um everything
is struggling you're trying to figure
out why and a soil test can really help
identify those challenges it can also be
helpful to establish a baseline maybe
you're putting in a new garden and you
want to see where your Baseline and your
soil is maybe you're looking at changing
some of your practices you're going to
change from a rotail garden to a noil
garden and you want to get it Baseline
on where your organic matter is you may
be going to spend a lot of money on
fertilizer maybe you have a very large
garden and you're are going to invest a
lot of money on fertilizer compost or
manure and you want to know what your
soil um nutrient status is before you
spend that money maybe you're just
curious maybe you just really find soil
chemistry fascinating and you would just
like to know what the chemistry of your
soil is like
you can also test the nutrient content
and the salt content of manure and
compost uh it's very similar you use the
same Labs there's similar reports but it
can be very useful if you are going to
add a large quantity of compost or
manure to your garden or to your small
farm and then you can test the nutrient
content of that
Amendment so soil chemistry test what
will the lab test for right you can
select variety of tests from any
different soil lab but here are some of
the Basics nitrate nitrogen so you're
going to be testing for nitrogen but it
comes in many forms it comes in a
nitrate ion it comes as an ammonium ion
and it also comes in the organic form so
what the soil is gonna soil labs are
going to test for primarily is nitrate
nitrogen ammonia nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium those are your big three your
macronutrients then some of your
micronutrients calcium magnesium and
sulfur they can be lumped in as macro or
micro they're kind of in the middle and
then some of your micronutrients zinc
iron manganese copper Boron um they're
variety of others but those can be also
helpful for identifying where your what
the nutrient status of your soil is also
you'll get a test for soil organic
matter they use um uh very very high
temperatures basically they burn off the
organic matter and then look at the
difference in the soil so that can be
very useful for monitoring over time uh
pH or the acidity of the soil and salts
also very useful especially here in
Wyoming where we have a lot of very
alkaline and very saline
soils and then the EC which is your
total dissolve salt so so that's the
that EC stands for electrolytic
conductivity and that is what you'll see
on your lab report typically is either
total salt or EC and I'll talk a little
bit more about that here in a few
minutes and then your sodium absorption
absorption Ratio or your your the
percent of the exchange sites in the
soil that are occupied by sodium and
that identifies the sodium hazard in
your soil or your water and there are
many different um ions that form salts
in soil and in water sodium is
particularly problematic and can be very
difficult to manage because of its large
ionic size so if you are concerned that
you have sodium issues in your soil the
getting tested the sodium absorption
ratio can be very
helpful this is a list of our primary
plant nutrients you can see at the top
your macronutrients nitrogen phosphorus
and potassium this list includes calcium
magnesium and sulfur also as
macronutrients and then it gets into all
your micronutrients here down the list
and what's interesting is this is just a
reminder about that why they're called
macro and micronutrients the relative
number of atoms in Plants right so for
any PL every plant for every one million
atoms of nitrogen you might have one of
meibum or nickel so that's why these are
called micronutrients you the plants
just need a lot less of them compared to
the
macronutrients this is also interesting
because it shows you the primary form of
plant uptake so for nitrogen plants
primarily take up the nitrate and the
ammonium ion for phosphorus they take up
phosphate and for potassium calcium and
magnesium they take up the pure ionic
form for sulfur they take it up in a
sulfate form and down the list so that's
just kind of interesting thing to see
what the plants use and then where these
nutrients come from organic matter is a
big one and then minerals um as the
minerals are weathered in the soil and
they start to break down slowly through
biological and um chemical processes
they rele nutrients into the soil that
the plants can use into the soil
solution so this just is a good example
of all the different um essential plant
nutrients that that come from the soil
of course the oxygen um or the carbon
and the hydrogen come from the water and
the air so this interesting things to
look at
here this is the nitrogen cycle and the
reason I wanted to share this is just an
example of of how all of these nutrients
move through the soil and go from um the
plant to the soil to through the or
through the microorganisms in the soil
back to the plant again it's a
continuous cycle right and remember a
lot of nitrogen comes from the organic
matter and what happens is as the
organic matter is is is broken down by
organisms in the soil by the bacteria
and fungi it releases nitrogen in the
ammonium and the nitrate form and this
is the primarily the form that the
plants can use some of that nitrate can
be lost through leeching through
excessive water moving through the soil
right and it's continually going back
and forth into organic matter and into
microbes and then back into the soil
solution so the plants can take it
up that's why when you have a lot of
organic matter in your soil it generally
Pro provides over time a slow steady
release of nitrogen for the plants to
use this is the phosphorus cycle there
are some key differences here notice the
small the pool of organic matter is cons
considerably smaller and there's a
little bit of Sol ution phosphorus here
right and then a lot of it comes from
the secondary minerals and compounds
what's particularly key is that this
small pool of of phosphorus in the
solution that the plants can take up
right that the plants can use it very
quickly depending on the soil chemistry
moves over here into these minerals and
is not available to plants the
precipitation process here right and and
and because of our high pH our very
alkaline and um saline high salt soils
but especially because of our alkaline
soils a lot of the phosphorus that might
otherwise be available to plants moves
over here into these minerals and is
unavailable however if we have high
organic matter in our soils and we
really work on building the organic
material in our soils this phosphorus
here is more available to the plants so
just something interesting here to keep
in mind with the with the phosphorus so
often there'll be phosphorus in the soil
but it is not available to the plants
interestingly enough iron is the same
here in our soils and so that's why
often we'll see iron deficiency even
though there's plenty of iron in the
soil it's just not plant
available manure and compost are great
sources of
phosphorus potassium is very simple um
it there we tend not to have shortages
here in our soils although occasionally
I've seen s shortages on Farm crops that
are grown in heavy Sandy or very Sandy
soils but again we have a lot of it in
solution means dissolved in the water in
the soil and um very little of it gets
gets um bound up in the minerals that
the plants can't use and so it's it's a
pretty simple story we rarely have
shortages of it but it is a it's very
important nutrient and it's important to
have
enough I mentioned soil PH a few times
that's the alkalinity of our soil
remember acid is low numbers down here
on this chart it starts at four for an
acidic pH and up to 10 for an alkaline
pH neutral is seven which is where most
plants prefer to grow based on nutrient
availability most of our soils in
Wyoming are the high sevens and even up
to eight and what you'll notice here is
that um the nutrient availability is
greatly affected by soil PH so um as the
pH creeps up above seven uh we start to
see a decrease in the availability of
phosphorus and a decrease in the
availability of a lot of these other
micronutrients iron copper and zinc for
example doesn't affect calcium very much
we actually see an increase in the
availability of magnesium potassium and
sulfur aren't greatly affected nor is
nitrogen but particularly phosphorus and
our micronutrients are less plant
available as the pH creeps up again
increasing the organic matter in the
soil will really help with this and some
plants are more tolerant of a high pH
than others right so uh those and
there's lists of that that you can get
that will help you determine what can
thrive in your soils blueberries are
kind of a classic example that really
prefer an acidic soil they're bog plants
typically so they don't Thrive here in
Wyoming without a lot of careful soil
management because they really prefer
acidic
soils soil solinity is another challenge
we have here in
Wyoming what happens is if you have ever
boiled a pot of water on the stove and
then what is Left Behind is a little bit
of these white residue and then less the
water's boiled off and the salts are
left behind that's what's happening in
the soil and so salt when it comes to
when we're talking about soil salinity
are basically positive and negative ions
that dissociate in water and almost all
of those ions with the exception of
sodium are essential plant nutrients and
so really it's an excess excess amount
of nutrients more than the plants can
use and what happens particularly when
you have bare soil and it's hot and you
may have salt in your water as the water
evaporates off the surface of the soil
the salts remain behind and accumulate
right and water um moves upward through
capillary
action so this is an important thing to
keep in mind what you'll often see white
crystals on the surface of the soil that
salts that have left been left behind
low-lying areas um will often have more
salts in them or on the surface to the
soil one of the most important things
you can do here is keep your soil
mulched no bare soil in the garden make
sure everything is really well mulched
that will keep the soil cool and mean
less water will evaporate and less salts
will be brought up from from under from
deeper in the soil the other thing you
can do is grow more salt tolerant plants
University of Wyoming extension has a
great bulletin that lists the salinity
tolerance of various Horticultural
plants that's a good
reference the other thing you can do if
you're really concerned about salty
irrigation water is to have your water
tested when you have your soil
tested and if you have high saline High
salts in your soil very saline soils
take care with what fertilizers and what
manure or compost you add because again
you have an excessive certain nutrients
in your soil so it's important to manage
carefully this is a general
classification when you get uh your soil
test results back you'll get a number
for your electrity electrolytic
conductivity and your soil PH and po
potentially your soil absorption ratio
if you have asked for that and this
shows you if you have greater than four
of an e EC greater than four you'll have
a Salan soil and your pH and various
things so these this is just an example
of what you're what you're looking at
here and again your the soil lab that
you work with or your local Extension
Office can help you interpret some of
these
results um so this is your total salt
and this is the ratio of sodium to
calcium and magnesium and that
determines your your sodium
problems so that was a little bit of a
chemistry lesson now let's talk about
how to collect samples for an accurate
lab interpretation so if you do do not
do a good job collecting samples the lab
will um only be able to give you results
that are as accurate as the samples
you've collected right so um divide your
property into management zones so you
may want to sample your lawn or your
garden or your pasture or maybe you have
two different Gard one in the front of
the house and one in the back of the
house that have been managed differently
over the years so separate your colle
sample collection areas into management
zones and leave out any really strange
areas so say you have a one acre garden
and one corner of it's always really a
little wetter or it's lower or it's
always really problematic SE sample that
separately because what you're going to
do is collect a variety of or collect
samples across the landscape or across
the garden and mix them all together for
what we call a composite
sample now if you have some really
strange area um one section that behaves
differently than the others and you mix
everything together you're not going to
get accurate results for either section
so separate those out you need about 10
s 10 to 15 samples collected for a
garden typically if you're sampling
pastures um or larger areas you'll need
more samples but for a garden typically
10 to 15 cores across the garden will be
just fine if it's a very small garden
you can get away with less but keep in
mind the more composite samp the more
samples you you take to make your
composite the more ACC accurate your
results will
be use clean tools don't use anything
that's Rusty or galvanized and you're
going to collect your sample down to a
depth of about six inches for Gardens
remove any bits of root um don't sample
where there's manure or anything like
that try and get a really clean sample
and then layer your samples out to air
dry on a clean paper bag or paper towels
or something where animals aren't going
to get to it or you're not going to
spill anything on it and keep everything
really
clean these here are some tools that you
can use um this is a soil probe here on
the left and soil augers it's a very
simple tool but you don't need to go buy
one often your extension um local
extension office or maybe your
Conservation District will have one you
can borrow but you can also use a shovel
so you'll go take your 10 to 15 core
samples across the landscape mix them in
a clean bucket and then lay them out to
dry that's the simplest way to do it
most Labs ask for about two cups of soil
if your sample um when you're done
collecting all your different cores and
you mix it together and you have maybe
four or five cups of soil mix it
together really uniformly and then take
out about the two cups that um the lab
requires and but make sure that that
soil is Thoroughly mixed so you don't
end up with sending a sample into the
lab that only accounts for half of your
pasture or your
garden if you don't have access to a
soil core a shovel can work really well
just dig a hole down about six to eight
inches and then take a slice off an inch
or two slice off the side of that hole
then um you can use that slice you can
actually slice down the middle of this
to take a strip of soil that's going to
be about similar to taking a soil core
right down the middle of this shovel
dump it in the bucket do that 10 more
times mix it all together and then
separate out your two cups if you do it
this way you're going to end up with a
lot more soil than you need so it's very
important to mix it uniformly before you
take out your sub
sample and there are a lot of videos if
you look particularly look at extension
resources and look up on YouTube some
videos on soil sampling they'll give you
some good resources and examples of how
to do
it so where do you send your sample
that's the next question find a lab that
is certified by the North American
proficiency testing program you can go
to their website and you can look up
different Labs there are several um
neighboring states we don't um have a
University of Wyoming lab anymore but
there are several in neighboring states
Colorado State University extension or
the Colorado State University soil
testing lab um is easy to work with as a
gardener because if you tell them that
you want a garden soil test their
results um are very easy to interpret
and they're designed for gardeners but
they're a little slower some of the
commercial Labs will turn around um the
samples a lot faster and get you results
faster but they may be harder to
interpret so there are many choices I
would suggest going to this website and
looking up some different labs in the
area make sure it's a certifed
lab so you get your results back this is
an example of um the soil test report I
should say though also when you're
looking at these Labs on their websites
they should have sampling um shipping
instructions and how they how much soil
they want and where they want it shipped
so if you have any questions you can
call the lab directly this is an example
of the result from a soil test that was
done by Colorado State University
extension specifically for Gardens now
notice it says native vegetation and the
proposed plant type is vegetable garden
so this individual was putting in a new
garden now the other thing to keep in
mind is that when you fill out your soil
test forms be as detailed as possible
about what was grown there what you're
going to grow because then they can give
you more accurate recommendations if
you're asking for a soil test or um
fertilizer recommendation so in this
particular case they go this is why the
CSU lab is great for for folks who are
less familiar with soil chemistry
because they very specific spefic
recommendations uh pH is high but native
and introduced plant species that are
adapted to this pH should not be
negatively affected EC is less than two
two so your salinity is not a problem
organic matter um the texture estimate
even
nitrate um they say nitrate here is low
apply and they give you some
recommendations for that um phosphorus
there's your soil test results and they
give you some recommendations on how
much to add um per square foot as
opposed to per which is Handy for most
gardeners they use give you some
different examples of what types of
fertilizer you can use to meet that need
they go through your micronutrients and
then um sometimes put some additional
comments here so this can be a a really
useful resource they just they sort of
provide everything you need here for the
interpretation and again be very
specific about what um what you're
growing so that they can give you
accurate
recommendations this is the CSU report
that's that's designed for agricultural
use notice it's um has it's it can it
has results for multiple Fields so this
particular producer sent in only one um
sample at a time but you could send in
five or six samples and they would all
come back on the same report maybe five
or six different fields that you had pH
salts um texture estimate that's
optional if you ask for it organic
matter percent and then it goes through
all of your um in parts per million all
of your different nutrients here now the
fertilizer recommendations this
particular producer asked for fertilizer
recommendations for oats and in order to
get accurate recommendations they need
to put the proposed crop and the yield
per acre goal so they wanted to grow
oats and with a yield goal of 110
bushels per acre so the soil lab can put
this information and the soil
information into their formulas and come
up with some fertilizer recommendations
they are suggesting 40 pounds per acre
of p25 and 80 pounds per acre of
nitrogen now as a producer you would
know your own field you may know what
you've done in the past but this gives
you a good place to start
this is a different lab this is Midwest
Laboratories uh again these are the
numbers the lab assigns this is the
sample identification that the producer
sent um that the producer labeled their
samples with so that this means
something to them has something to do
with their fields organic matter percent
and then the different phosphorus and
they have little notes here that says
very high medium
High um very low and that's their a
little bit of interpretation there that
can help you determine how to use these
numbers cation exchange capacity this is
the ability of the soil to exchange
nutrients um their nitrate is down here
you can also do depth so sometimes
you'll sample 0 to six inches and then
six to 12 inches depending on what
you're doing but again these are more
detailed reports so just another example
of what might come back from the lab for
you to look
at this is another interesting thing you
can do at home this is um this little
infographic says it's t to identify your
soil type but that's actually inaccurate
what you are really identifying here is
your soil texture your percent of sand
silt and Clay so this can be an easy
thing to do at home do it with the kids
it's kind of interesting it can help you
look at some of the different um
characteristics of your soil makes the
water in the jar with the soil and let
it sit for a day or two and it settles
out into sand silk and clay and organic
matter kind of floats on the top and
then you're able to see what the soil
textural differences are in your soil
so I I think it's important to touch
briefly on the difference between a
fertilizer and a soil amendment when it
comes to identifying the needs in your
soil so a fertilizer when you're
applying a fertilizer it's a source of
very specific nutrients Rapid Release
and availability generally has your
macro it's labeled with your
macronutrients you'll see numbers there
10 10 10 or something that says uh 10%
nitrogen 10% phosphorus 10% potassium so
it tells you what's in it uh it can be
synthetic or organic um and some manure
like ping manure would could go into the
fertilizer category but Rapid Release
and availability it's for use now or
within a growing season a soil amendment
is a source of organic matter typically
and long-term nutrients and a benefit to
soil Health it's a long-term investment
it's going to release nutrients slowly
over time it's going to support the soil
biology and it's going to increase your
soil health over time compost rage
manure and cover crops are examples of
this so for example Miracle Grow plant
food that's an example of a fertilizer
see the number here Aller purpose plant
food 24816 that means it's 24% nitrogen
8% p205 and 16% uh k2o or poach right
and you can look down here it has it has
the breakdown of what that is right and
then you'll notice that there they are
slightly different blends based on All
Purpose this plant food um or the rose
plant food is slightly different right
so that's when you know it's a
fertilizer right and it tells you what
it's made of these are synthetic
fertilizers here on the label it tells
you what's in it
these are examples of soil amendments so
composted manure look at the very low
nutrient content per weight based on
compared to the fertilizer a um
0.05% right as opposed to here we're
looking at like 24% nitrogen so again a
nutrient-rich blend promotes root growth
improves soil quality over time
long-term investment in soil Health very
important over the long term uh uh grass
clippings and leaves you can compost
that at home food waste is is a worm bin
that I keep at the office worm castings
are great for the soil so think about
you're going to have less short-term
nutrient benefit long more long-term
slow release nutrients and benefit of
soil
health so how do we interpret our
results now we understand the chemistry
we've talked a little bit about biology
we got these lab results in front of us
what do we do with those these are two
of the best bulletins that I found for
interpreting um soil test results for
gardeners one is the soil test
interpretation guide that comes comes
from Oregon State University you can
look that up and then Colorado State
University has a soil test explanation
bulletin that's also very good and
simple and to the point so I would
encourage you to look up both of those
if you have a soil test you need
interpreting and um speak with the lab
that you're working with they often have
interpretation guides available as well
so good luck um and if you um need
assistance or might need to borrow some
tools contact your local extension
office and best of luck in the garden